women have been lied to,
and the worst part is it's .coming from other women
The belief that “if he wanted to he would”
that's actually the worst advice
We hear it all the time
and it's literally a joke at this point.
so I asked my dad,
uncle, and brother what they thought about this,
and their response genuinely surprised me.
Their response was it's simply not true
because most of the time
they literally don't know.
Unless you're direct and communicate your needs,
they don't understand this,
half the time
they don't understand how to meet your needs
Not only that
some men have never been given examples of how to treat a woman properly
they're figuring out life
just like we are
The saying should really go
“if you want him to, you should tell him”
Directly, and I mean directly as possible
You want him to text you “good morning beautiful”?
TELL HIM to!
if you want him to get you flowers, tell him to!
if you want him to grab you coffee in the morning
or just surprise you in general, tell him to!
want him to pump your gas?
then tell him directly and tell them your needs
Don’t wait later down the road and compare your relationship with other people
for all you know
they're probably just really good at communicating their wants and needs
How do we expect them to know if we don't tell them?
Take initiative and speak directly
if you want your man to surprise you with gifts,
flowers, or do pleasant things for you.
If you want your needs met,
speak directly,
communicate, it's that simple.